التاريخ لا ينسى ولا يرحم،
الاتحاد الروسي بعظمته
ضد دولة مسلمة صغيرة لا حول لها ولا قوة،
هجمات متتالية طوال عام كامل،
قادتها وحدات الجيش الروسي على الشيشان،
رضخ الروس لوقف إطلاق النار،
بعد أن واجهوا وحوشا يذودون عن أرضهم،
ونساءا بدور بطولي،
نساء لم يوقف جمالهن الساحر بطولاتهن وانتصاراتهن
للدفاع عن الوطن،
لم يدافعن عن الأرض فقط بل انتقلن إلى أرض العدو أيضا
ذهب الرئيس الروسي وجاء من بعده آخر
حاملاً نار الانتقام في صدره،
والدولة الصغيرة مغلوب على أمرها،
تدافع عن نفسها بإمكانياتها البسيطة ولكن بعزيمة تفتت
الصخر وتهز الجبال، .....
حرب روسيا في الشيشان  ...
للقصة بقية،،
في القرن التاسع عشر، وفي الحرب الأولى
استطاع الاتحاد السوفييتي السيطرة على الشيشان
وجعلها تحت وصايته، لكن ومع نهاية القرن العشرين،
أخذ الشيشانيون بثأرهم وطردوا المحتل السوفييتي،
خصوصا مع انشغاله بلملمة ماتبقى من الدولة عام ١٩٩١،
وخلال عام من الاستقلال دخلت الشيشان في حرب أهلية
وانقسمت إلى قسمين، ، حتى جاء عام ١٩٩٤
وعادت القوات الروسية إلى الشيشان لاستعادة النظام الدستوري
، دارت معارك وحشية، وقتال دامٍ خلال عامين
قتل خلالها ما يصل إلى١٠٠ألف شخص،
ما أدى لوقف القتال وسحب روسيا لجنودها من جمهورية الشيشان
جراء الخسائر الفادحة في الأرواح والعتاد،،،
دخل الجيش الروسي إلى الشيشان عام ١٩٩٥
وارتكب مجازر بشعة، لقد وصلوا بجيش قوامه ٣٠ ألف مقاتل
لم يعد منهم سوى الآلاف،
..الحرب الثانية..
عندما هدأت الحرب، أوقدها فلاديمير بوتين،
إذ جاء منتقما، وما وصوله للحكم
إلا فرصة ليأخذ ثأر الجنود الروس، وينتقم أشد انتقام
من الشيشانيين الذين دافعوا عن أرضهم،
فبوتين لا يهمه أكان على حق أو على باطل
فالمهم أن يسترد كرامة دولته ولو على حساب دولة ضعيفة،
دولة أصبحت النساء فيها تحتجز رهائن العدو،
دولة كثرت فيها النساء المسلحات ليساعدن الرجال للدفاع عن الوطن،
وقالت إحدى هؤلاء المسلحات في  فيديو مسجل:
"لا يهمنا إن متنا، لقد اخترنا أن نموت هنا في موسكو،
وسنأخذ معنا أرواح الكفار"،
إذا كانت النساء هكذا فكيف بالرجال،
عندها فشلت روسيا حقا في حرب  السنوات الثلاث
وتأججت بداخلها نار الانتقام،
فقررت العودة للأراضي الشيشانية ،
أطلق فلاديمير جيشه وقصف برا وجوا،
وخلال شهر واحد دمر ٦٠%من البنية التحتية للشيشان،
همجية بوتين شملت الأرواح المسلمة كذلك،
لكنه أخذ درسه من الحرب الأولى فجاء بطريقة جديدة معروفة
بالأرض المحروقة،
تم قصف  وتدمير القرى والمدن الآهلة بالسكان
ليهجرها من بقي فيها حيا وينزح إلى منطقة آمنة،
وفي عام ٢٠٠٢ صارت عاصمة الشيشان غروزني خالية من الناس،
عندها دخل الجيش الروسي إلى العاصمة ورفع أعلامهم،
وبين غارات متواصلة وسرق ونهب
وقتل وتفجير وتدمير انتهت الحياة تماما في الشيشان
وقتل خلال هذه الفترة ٢٠٠ألف شخص،
وفي العام ٢٠٠٩ أعلنت الحكومة الروسية انتهاء العمليات العسكرية
في الشيشان وسحب الجزء الأكبر من جيشها،
بعد بحور من الدم وبعد أن انتهكت الحقوق الإنسانية
ودمرت كل ما استطاعت من مظاهر الحياة،
لكن بالمقابل الشيشانيون لم يصمتوا
وقتلوا الكثير من الجنود الروس بين عمليات انتحارية
ومبانٍ مفخخة وعمليات نوعية،
وكبدوا الروس خسائر بالغة،
وأعلنوا للعالم على الرغم من قلتهم وضعفهم،
بأنهم لن يتركوا حقهم وسيقاتلون حتى آخر رمق
في سبيل الاستقلال وهو ما حدث.